okay great okay let's start
I'm Barbara me I'm one of the owners
here at politics and prose and this
evening I want to welcome max hasting to
talk about his new book Armageddon about
the final battle for Germany the
military historian John Keegan has
previously praised Hastings work as
worthy to stand with that of the best
journalists and writers and I think that
most readers of his new book will agree
with me that he really has become the
foremost chronicler of world war ii it
was a war that caused such death such
devastation such suffering that it's
almost impossible to amend to imagine if
you can imagine 27 million citizens of
the Soviet Union were killed during the
war I think it's a tribute to Hastings
narrative style that he can keep the
reader going through all this savagery
that was occurring especially on the
Eastern Front I think this book is
timely in some ways because one of the
aspects that max hazing is interested in
is the morality of war and one of the
things that he talks about is a
particular savagery of the Germans and
the Russians he has a quotation I'll
read it from the book about the American
and the British forces he said he says
that the American soldiers fought as
bravely and as well as any democracy
could ask if the values of the
civilization were to be retained in
their ranks in doing so their Vig their
victory was more protracted than it
might have been but they retained a
civilized stance in their military
actions
I hope that at some point that future
historians and maybe Max Hastings can
fill in in military history how we got
from that standard of conduct in World
War two for American soldiers to the
standards of some cultures of our
military today and here's max Hastings
well thank you very much Barbara for
that very kind introduction
a dictionary defines Armageddon
as the site of the decisive battle on
the day of judgment and hence a final
contest on a grand scale
the last campaigns of the Second World
War
locked him bloody embrace more than a
hundred million people within and
without the frontiers of Hitler's Third
Reich their outcome drastically
influenced the lives of many more the
Second World War was the most disastrous
human experience in history and it's
closing months provided an appropriately
terrible climax twenty years ago in my
earlier book Overlord I described the
1944 d-day invasion of Europe and the
campaign in Normandy now that narrative
ended with the American and British
breakthrough in August followed by a
triumphant dash across France many
allied soldiers believed that the
collapse of Hitler's Empire must swiftly
follow the British Joint Intelligence
Committee declared that for planning
purposes it might be assumed that
Germany would collapse by the 31st of
December 1944 most frontline commanders
including Montgomery and Eisenhower of
the same opinion only Winston Churchill
disagreed no man knew better than
Britain's Prime Minister just how
formidable were the fighting powers of
the German army and he responded to that
jic note by asserting first that he
thought it much more likely than not
that the Germans would still be fighting
in 1945 and second that if they weren't
this would be because of a political
collapse in Germany are not a military
one
now my starting point for writing
Armageddon was personal curiosity to see
why the Allies didn't win the war in
1944 as everybody expected in August and
as our vast superiority of resources
suggested in the West the Allies
possessed 2,000 tanks against less than
a hundred German 14,000 aircraft against
a few hundred of the Luftwaffe and we
should remember that back in nineteen
forty and forty one the British
attributed most of their defeats to the
superiority of the German air force
Hitler's army even in the last months of
the war was the most formidable fighting
force that the world had ever seen
the Western Allies to the very end
displayed all the limitations and
inhibitions of citizen armies when most
of their soldiers now confident that the
Allies were going to win the war well
pathetically and very understandably
eager to be around to share in the
victory and to go home to their loved
ones I've always been struck by a story
I was told some years ago by a colonel
one of his sergeant majors one a
Victoria Cross in Normandy this man
called company sergeant major Stan
Hollis and three times on d-day and in
the days that followed that Hollis's
battalion the green hearts were held up
by German strong points and company
commander would say I'm Sami do you see
that German position over there it's
holding us up and Hollis would say I'm
yes son
pick up a submachine gun and a few
grenades and charge it it and take out
the Germans and so the advance moved on
now most people who did things like that
were killed
Hollis survived and was awarded a very
well-deserved Victoria Cross and lived
to keep a pub in Yorkshire after the war
but um when I was talking to his colonel
thirty or forty years after the event
his colonel said he said you know he
said I think and of course the whole war
Stan Hollis was the only man I met who
felt that winning it was his personal
responsibility he said everybody else
when there was something terrible to be
done looked around and hoped that some
other poor bugger could be found to do
it but in this book Oh
though I still have argued that the
German performance was by far the
outstanding one of the war I've added
what I think is a very important
corollary in many ways one of the most
admirable things about the American and
British armies in the Second World War
was the Namid total catastrophe they
preserve most of the inhibitions and
decencies of democracies at war their
soldiers didn't like killing people or
I'm raising towns massacring innocents
under the time I finished writing
Armageddon I find myself thinking if
American soldiers and British soldiers
has been as ferocious warriors as the
waffen-ss a suicidally brave as some men
of the Red Army they would have needed
to be people like them imbued with the
ethos of tyranny and savagery and if
that had been so then the very purpose
for which the war was being fought would
have been set at naught and I've argued
that the British American army is in
4445 till as well as anyone could have
expected given the sort of people that
they were a former Red Army tank officer
delightful wonderfully articulate man
named Joe not even off whom I met Kazan
in Austria he said we were living in a
time in which human life possessed
absolutely no value all that mattered
was to stay alive oneself I felt very
conscious as I was writing Armageddon
but this is the last decade in which one
will be privileged to be able usefully
to interview people who lived through
all these remarkable and terrible
experiences when I started researching
this period almost 30 years ago I was
able to meet people that served as
generals today nobody whom I saw held a
rank higher than major many of them
still recall what happened to them are
amazingly vividly but they are getting
very old and it's very moving to see
those young men and women who you see in
their photographs was
fresh and vital and often brave and
handsome and who did so many remarkable
things 60 years ago today stooped and
frail the destiny of us all a cultural
collision took place in Germany in 1945
between societies whose experience of
the war was light-years apart what the
Soviet and German people's did as well
as what was done to them for very little
resemblance to the war that the
Americans and British knew there was a
chasm between the world of the Western
Allies populated by people who were
still striving to act temperately and
the eastern universe in which on both
sides
elemental passions dominated the lives
of stalin subjects embraced unspeakable
miseries even before the Nazis entered
the story I met a lot of people whose
families perished in the famines and
purges of the pre 1941 era one man
described to me how his parents who were
illiterate peasants were anonymously
denounced by neighbors as counter
revolutionaries one shot in 1939 of the
prison outside San Petersburg and a
woman who was listening to our
conversation interjected in exactly the
same voice that we might use talking
about somebody who Bennett we found
somebody been at the same school said oh
my parents were shot at that prison too
and after she spoke another woman put in
speaking rather darkly she said you
shouldn't be talking about things like
that
in front of a foreigner in Russia
there's no tradition of pursuing
objective historical truth even in the
21st century it remains difficult to
persuade a fiercely nationalistic people
to speak frankly about the bleaker
aspects of their wartime history
some historians try to write a russia's
commander's as if they were people cast
in the same mold as their Western
counterparts they were not they were
brutes because none but brutes have a
military talented could have prospered
in Stalin's universe steeped in blood
consider that great commander raucous
offski he started the war without his
finger
because they've been torn out during his
incarceration in the purges once later
on the war when Zhukov complained about
Stalin's terrible secret policemen
barrier and raucous offski burst in he
said don't talk to me about barrier he
growled
I've seen his prisons in the first two
years of the war alone the Red Army
executed one hundred and sixty-seven
thousand of their own men for alleged
cowardice or desertion Zhukov made his
reputation commanding the defense of
Leningrad he had a line of tanks behind
the front not to deal with the Germans
but to shoot any of his own people who
tried to run away and so they did
Stalin liked to tell a story all the
time when he lost a favorite pipe and he
mentioned this tube area and a couple of
days later bury a telephone diem and he
said as if any news of your pipe and
Stalin said yes he said I found it and
it rolled under the sofa barrier said
impossible three people have already
confessed to this crime as Barbara
mentioned at least 27 million Soviet
citizens died in the war against less
than a million British American and
French people combined and of course the
war American and British ground troops
killed about 200,000 Germans the
Russians killed three and a half million
as for the Germans a few years ago I
stood in front of a television camera on
Hitler's rostrum at Nuremberg and I said
how much I admired the courage with
which the post-war generation had
confronted the Nazi legacy
well after we finished filming our
researcher who was a young German woman
who worked on a lot of documentaries
about the period came up to me and she
said excuse me she said I think you're
wrong she said I think our people are
still in denial about the war well I've
still I've thought a lot about what she
said since and I concluded she's partly
right
some young Germans many young Germans
extraordinary ignorant about the Nazi
period and some older ones seem less
troubled today about
the horrors of the Nazi period than some
English people are about the alleged
crimes of the British Empire it's as if
the horrors of the Nazi era were
committed by people quite unrelated to
the law-abiding tax-paying pensioners
who now occupy comfortable retirement
homes in Munich or Stuttgart Nuremberg
or Dresden citizens in good standing of
the European Union
one former waffen-ss captain whom I met
and I spent some hours listening to his
appalling tales of battle on the eastern
and western fronts from 1941 to 45 and I
found he sounded almost nostalgic and I
said to him intending to be ironic that
he seemed to have enjoyed his experience
as a soldier he said they were great
days so the two biggest moments of my
life
1934 taking the oath to the livest and
art I hid this bodyguard Nuremberg 1936
said you've seen the newsreels the
searchlights the crowds the Fuhrer I was
there I was there by contrast many Red
Army veterans are today deeply
embittered by their poverty they have a
saying it would have been better if the
fascists that won the war because now we
could all be living like the Germans
when I started interviewing Russian
veterans my researcher asked if I give
each one $20 well I said this seemed
insulting I'm surely it ought to be $100
and she said you don't understand
$20 is more than their monthly pensions
those men who fought for the Red Army in
World War two have been left behind as
tragic flotsam of history and many
suffered almost as terribly at Stalin's
hands after the war was over than from
the Germans when it was going on
although in this book I told the story
of what happened militarily a bubble
Armageddon aspires to describe a vast
and terrible human experience
although I've written a lot about Stalin
Churchill Roosevelt Hitler
my real purpose is to paint a portrait
of
what happened to a host of ordinary
people to whom extraordinary things
happened consider the two million
Germans who fled from East Prussia and
Silesia in January 1945 through 4 feet
of snow temperatures 25 below amid the
Soviet onslaught anything up to a
million Germans many of them women and
children died in that terrible flight
amid the shells and bombs of the Red
Army now one survivor said to me it was
our Holocaust but nobody cares her
choice of words was in very poor taste
but it's true that most people in the
West have remained blithely ignorant of
the vast experiment in ethnic cleansing
which took place in Eastern Europe in
1945 because the victims were Germans
then there were the Dutch people who
starved through the winter of 1944 in
which their experiences were terrible
and remained largely unnoticed in
British and American books about the
period in their way the Dutch were
treated as ruthlessly by Eisenhower and
his armies as well the people of Warsaw
in the autumn of 1944 when the Red Army
left them to suffer and die the Dutch
ate tulip bulbs and died in thousands of
malnutrition because the Western Allies
were convinced probably rightly but
nonetheless very painfully that British
and American soldiers should not be
diverted from the drive into Germany in
order to liberate Holland our generation
some of the ignorant members of it
sometimes kid themselves that we live in
a uniquely dangerous and frightening age
the war on terror al Qaeda yet I suspect
that most of us here today would agree
that we're a uniquely privileged
generation are compared with those who
went before when I was writing this book
I had letter from a woman living in
England who said said I'm German and I
was in Berlin in 1945 and I kept a diary
would you like to sit
and she sent me her diary which
described in the most vivid and moving
terms her experiences first of all
working for the German labour service
and then in April 1945 while the Battle
for Berlin was going on she aged 17 and
her sister were hiding in their
apartment in Berlin with their parents
when our Russian soldiers burst him and
they were repeatedly raped as most women
in Berlin were and when eventually the
Russians went leaving them all sobbing
their mother stood up and said your
honour is gone your lives are finished
their mother took these two sisters to
the roof of the apartment building and
tell them to jump their father stood on
the sidewalk underneath begging them not
to in the end after ten minutes they
burst into tears and ran back in the
house and survived the woman
two years afterwards came to England as
a volunteer farm worker and stayed and
married Englishman has lived there ever
since
but for that tiny number who survived
those sort of experiences tens of
thousands perhaps hundreds of thousands
did kill themselves under those
circumstances consider the story of me
Kyle Divya tyre who's one of the most
remarkable men I've ever met he was a
Soviet fighter pilot and in beginning of
45 he was shot down over the German
lines and my badly injured and he spent
some weeks in a prison hospital where he
took the precaution of changing
identities with a dead Red Army soldier
because the Germans had a habit of
treating Russian pilots very badly
well when he got out of hospital he was
sent as a slave laborer to Peenemunde on
the baltic well they were building the
v2 and um he'd only been in the camp for
a few days
when he came inclusion that he stayed
there he was going to die because they
were dying of starvation and from undies
unexploded bombs they were carrying at
the rate of about 1,500 a week on anyway
he figured
the Germans would probably shoot the
survivors before the Red Army got them
so he said to the rest of his work gang
eight of them he said we're going to
escape and they said how can we this is
an island they wanted ever escaped so
everybody's tried has been torn to
pieces by the dogs and he said I'm a
pilot I'm gonna fly you out well he took
some days to convince them that he could
do it and it was possible and that the
alternative was staying was worse but
one morning in February 1945 they
clubbed their guard to death and ran 400
yards along the runway to the common
denial with considerable difficulty they
managed to get into it and get it
started and getting into the air and it
was very difficult because um
Debbi attire for never flown a
twin-engined aircraft and he couldn't
get the undercarriage out he had
enormous difficulty figuring out how to
fly this airplane also they were so weak
that he had to have another person a
leaning over his shoulder to help him
move the controls because he couldn't
move the controls himself Wellborn hour
and a half they didn't really fly they
lurched over the Baltic until they made
a landfall and they saw underneath them
red soldiers and they crashed landed in
the snow and they were so weak um that
they couldn't move they just sat in the
fuze large until a red army cavalry
patrol arrived well the first few hours
armed they were treated as heroes as God
knows they deserved to be because I
don't think I've ever heard a more
remarkable story of the Second World War
but then start in secret police the NKVD
arrived and began to interrogate them
and after some hours the NKVD said what
you claim to have done is impossible
this is a German plot well I said to
Derby Table eight dive when you spend
fee day and he said where I spent the
next job and solitary confinement the
other eight men in his work gang were
sent to a punishment battalion and five
of them were killed clearing mines and
the crossing of the oder debía tie if
they had to admit there might be
something in what he said because when
they liberated Peenemunde row of course
the survivors confirm the story but the
NK mean he never admitted
that it was entirely wrong every
prisoner who came back from Germany
whatever the circumstances in which
they've been captured had their papers
stamped by the Soviets that this was a
politically suspect person and they
carried those papers with that brand for
the rest of their lives and Debbie
attire lived on the edge of bigger e as
many many other X prisoners did until
1957 when after Stalin's death the
Soviet Union recognized the truth of
historian gave in the middle as a hero
of the Soviet Union but when you hear
stories like this and I could stay here
all night telling not totally the
similar stories about the horrors which
Stalin inflicted on his own people um
I was left thinking that it sometimes
seemed as if the Western Allies were
simply uncomprehending eavesdroppers
upon a great and terrible death struggle
taking place in the East between rival
tyrannies who differed only in the
manner of the evils that they
represented I've not written a lot about
the Battle of Berlin because others most
notably and recently my friend Antony
Bieber have done it very well I've only
written about Berlin insofar as I've
found new stuff and they Soviet archives
which I think deserves an audience I
have written a lot about what happened
in East Prussia about what I called the
season of blood and ice because the
experiences that came out of there are
so extraordinary um one of the most
remarkable men that I met was called
Michael White Michael white was an East
Prussian Jew teenager and he and his
family his father was superintendents of
the musical Seminary in königsberg in
East Prussia and armed they went through
all the ghast experiences that Jews did
through the Nazi era except one that
they somehow miraculously avoided being
sent to concentration camp but they were
always all through the last phase of the
war they were clinging to life by their
fingernails
that they've been thrown out of their
apartment they lost their jobs they had
no food they weren't allowed to go into
air-raid shelters when the place was
bombed they were just clinging on prey
the Russians arrived before somebody
noticed them and sent them off to the
gas chambers well finally one day after
the terrible siege of chronics burg
April 1945 the Soviets burst in on the
only people in königsberg who welcomed
them and ran out to embrace them as
liberators of the white family in their
yellow stars and the Russians take no
notice and push them in with all the
other germans and when they finally see
a russian jewish officer they said look
we're not with these people were Jews
well we're thrilled a seal and the
Russian officer said if you were really
Jews you would be dead as you're not we
have to assume you were with them so why
can his parents spent the next two weeks
clearing bodies in königsberg and he
described he was 15 at the time he
described all the scenes
all the people who kill themselves
they're having to cut down and women
who've been raped for the Russians and
so on and throw them all into bomb
craters in the street and fill them in
with tanks and after a few weeks of this
um he did something that upset the
Russians and he was sent to a Russian
concentration camp which was actually an
old German one which the Russians are
now had turned around and put Germans in
and he was there for about two months
and most of the people who were there
with him died and he described his
experiences there with ghastly clarity
arm and when he came out he eventually
was freed he managed to make friends for
the Russian officer who had him laid out
and he spent the next two years are
making a scratching a living playing the
violin in cafes armed to amuse Russian
soldiers and then in 1947 he escaped to
the west and I in the West he made a
great success as a musician and as a
writer speaks very good English and when
I sat listening to him I was enchanted
by him um he lives in Stuttgart and when
I'd finished listening this
extraordinary story I said
you must have felt that your childhood
was stolen from you and he said no he
said I didn't feel that at all he said I
met so many people who had what are
so-called normal childhoods who the rest
of their lives have been terrible he
said my childhood was different from
other people but he said my life since
1947 has been wonderful so he said
you're not going to hear me express any
anger towards either
the Germans are or the Russian people
and I was so moved that a man who had
endured such extraordinary experiences
could display such generosity of spirit
but it does put all our humble little
troubles into a sort of perspective I
hope that readers of my book will find a
lot that's new to them as its discovery
was new to me I began writing books
about this period 25 years ago but
familiarity does nothing to diminish
once all for the summit's of courage
that some men and women attained on the
depths of baseness that others plumbed
one woman I met who impressed me
enormously um American Army nurse called
Dorothea beavers whom I interviewed down
in Delaware and she was telling me a
story she'd been working on evidence II
concentration camp at the end of the war
and she was saying how astonished they
were when they found there's a whole
group of Hungarian Jewish women who all
spoke pretty good English very highly
educated but at the last extremes of
starvation and disease and a Life
magazine photographer turned up and one
of these girls ran so being away from
the photographer and Dorothea B was ran
after and put her arm round her and and
was trying to comfort her this woman
said look at me she said I'm 20 years
old and what man is ever gonna want to
look at me what would I be listening
Dorothea Bevers I said what happened to
that woman and amazingly she said what
she now lives in Queens and so when I
was back up in New York I arranged to go
and see her name's Edith Gabor
and I went to spend three or four hours
talking to Edith Gabor in Queens and
listening to her stories of his
accession of concentration camps and
then I ordered a cab to take me to
Kennedy to fly back to London the cab
didn't come and I got very fed up and
impatient and um I'm really almost
literally jumping up down the sidewalk
and Edith Gabor came out on the sidewalk
and she laughed and she said relax she
said it's not important
she said he doesn't matter she said when
you've been in a death camp you get to
see the missing an aeroplane really
doesn't matter so much
now I blush then as I blush now that I
could have displayed before such a woman
um a preoccupation with trivia which is
completely characteristic of all our
lives in the 21st century and which our
parents and grandparents are perforce
shed between 1939 and 1945 my own
gratitude has never diminished that our
generation has been spared
what there's endured and I believe
passionately and the truth of the words
inscribed on so many of war memorials in
the United States and Britain they died
that we might live we should never
forget that the vast majority of those
who fought the war did not think of
themselves as soldiers as warriors they
were civilians ordinary people truck
drivers and laborers and Bank Clark's
swept up by the tide of history into an
unwelcome seasons masquerade as warriors
this is some the most ambitious book
that I've ever written because it tries
to cover a vast canvas to record an epic
not only a military history but above
all of human experience it's sometimes
suggested that too many books are
written about the Second World War and
yet the stories that are still untold
about the saga
ashay extraordinary that it seems a
privilege to make a modest contribution
to recording them and to setting them in
the Khan
texts of the most significant event of
the 20th century thank you all very much
indeed if anybody would like to ask
questions that I'd say do shout because
I'm frightfully deaf
I'll try the mic by-and-large certainly
on the western side the press and by
that I mean the newspapers and the radio
in those days was largely if not
entirely supportive of the war effort
it's hard to recall critical press of
anything to do with the war effort
including the huge casualties that even
the Western powers suffered I was
wondering if you had any insight or any
thought how that might have how it might
have affected the conduct of the war had
we had as critical a press then as we
have now of military actions well I
spent I can't offer a little insight
because my father was war correspondent
in the Second World War a picture post
which was a sort of equivalent of Life
magazine and I've done a certain amount
of war Christ money myself in various
spots the world when I was a teenager
and I read a book my father published
during the war about his experience with
the three services and I said oh come on
father this is all a bit gung-ho you
know you make it sound as if bomber
pilots going out to attack the
Scharnhorst and then neither were really
regarded all this is a great party
whereas they must in fact have been
absolutely frightened stiff and so on
and my father said you don't understand
boy we were part of the war effort
I think there is bound to be a
distinction which I also think is a
valid distinction between what you
expect from the media and a war of
national survival and what you expect
for the media in a war of choice and all
wars are in considerable degree since
the Second World War wars of choice and
I'm not persuaded that it would have
served the cause of our democracy any
better to exercise yes you're absolutely
correct of course that in the Second
World War broadly to give the most
obvious example if a war correspondent
saw an American or British soldiers
shooting prisoners he wouldn't for a
moment think of trying to
report it even in the unlikely event
that the sense that would have allowed
him to do so
but I do think different rules have to
apply in Wars of choice although there's
always going to be fierce arguments
about exactly how these should be
interpreted there's always been a
question whether Eisenhower move fast
enough to get to Berlin do you comment
about that in the book or do you can
either be you couldn't not the real
point it's a huge subject I want to go
on about this all night because the real
question soft sergeant Henry Kissinger
whom I interviewed for the book that
Kissinger said he said yeah he said
Shawn Roosevelt the United States were
naive in their perceptions of Stalin and
about Eastern Europe but he said you
have to remember that the United States
went into the Second World War its
policy at the second world war was
directed to show that it was a different
sort of power from other powers that had
ever been at Wars in wars it was
determined to show that it had no
territorial ambitions and this
influenced everything that the Americans
did that Eisenhower was not sent to
Europe with a mandate from the United
States government to organize the shape
of post-war Europe he was sent with one
with a military mission to destroy
Hitler and to end the Nazi tyranny now
the very complex issue Churchill
Churchill's relations with Roosevelt
deteriorated dramatically in the last
year of the war to the point that I'm
among those historians who believe that
Churchill's non-attendance that
Roosevelt's funeral wasn't as Churchill
said at the time a matter of logistics I
think that he didn't want to be there he
was so bitter what he felt was
Roosevelt's arm lack of interest in the
fate of Eastern Europe now Roosevelt in
his terms was entitled to argue that
Churchill was naive because the blunt
truth the matter was the Russians were
there first the Russians were on the
ground already
and if the Western Allies had been
absolutely determined to deny Stalin
what he perceived as his blood price for
the sacrifice that the Soviet Union had
made of him
then first of all the Western Allies
would have had to have fought the war in
a completely different way from a much
earlier stage d-day would have had to
have been pushed forward the Allies
would have had to push through into
northwest Europe with a ruthlessness
which would have cost a lot more lives
and in the end if one's pulling it
absolutely bluntly the only way that um
Stalin might have been denied his booty
in Eastern Europe is if the Western
Allies had been prepared to fight him
and I doubt whether there's anyone in
this room who believes that in 1945
anybody in the United States or Britain
had the appetite to go to war with the
Soviet Union over Eastern Europe
and so of course it was an unspeakable
tragedy the fate of Poland I've written
quite a bit in my book what the Soviets
did in Poland was beyond unspeakable in
many ways they behaved at least as badly
as the Germans arguably worse and
Churchill of course was consumed with
misery here was the British and the
French had gone to war in September 1939
as a matter of principle in support of
Polish freedom and there they had to
stand by and see the poles it's a very
little-known fact
guerilla war went on in Poland long
after VE Day it was not between the
Germans and anybody it was between the
Red Army and the wretched Polish
Democrats who were still fighting for
the right to self-determination and whom
Starlin was determined should be crushed
and I read all the all the papers are
there in the in the Russian files though
as late as October 45 they had five NKVD
divisions engaged in guerrilla war with
the surviving poles just ruthlessly
blotting them out one of the most
terrible stories there was a famous
society darest in Britain called chips
Chanin who actually was american-born
arm and one day quite soon after the war
ended one of the first big society balls
given in in Britain which everybody was
waltzing around in their tiaras and
white tie and Tails and ships Chanin
turned to his neighbor a famous hostess
called Lady Coonan
and he said don't you feel this is what
we've all been fighting for lady Cunard
turns him in the moments of blinding
penetration she said what are they all
poles
and this was it was a it's it's a the
phrase still echoes with me and with as
it did with many people of that
generation that the the plight of Poland
at the end of it all was tragic but to
go back to your question about Berlin
and I do not think that the wives and
mothers of American and British soldiers
in 1945 with a thanked Eisenhower for
driving to Berlin when it was already
long decided that this would fall within
the Soviet zone of occupation for a
symbolic triumph that I also believe
that starting was so determined that the
Soviets should have that triumph that if
the Western Allies had pushed on the
Soviets would have thrown everything
everything into getting them the Battle
for Berlin was a shambles because the
Soviets were impelled not by tactical
considerations to do with meeting the
germs but this menak lusts for glory
between Kanye Zhukov and of course
ultimately Stalin and whatever one says
about some pretty Dottie Western
commanders I don't he would suggest that
any of them sacrificed the lives of
their own men in that fashion for pure
personal vain glory yes many Germans
criticized the Allies for giving up too
much land to their Russians and do you
think that's a valid argument they were
there first it's really the corollary of
what I was saying a moment ago that
you'd have had to go about the whole
game Stalin was the one warlord darling
was the most effective warlord of the
Second World War
because once he got over his terror that
he was going to lose back in 41 42 that
Stalin set an agenda for what he wanted
for himself and the Soviet Union out of
the war and pursued it ruthlessly so
that by the end of the war the United
States got some of the things that
wanted Britain got a few other things it
wanted the Soviet Union got everything
it wanted and that was done by absolute
ruthlessness and again denied the
Soviets their prizes they were there
they were on the ground they were in
Poland they were you know at the borders
of Poland I'm almost the time d-day came
and how could the West without having
started the war and a completely
different spirit and and
pursued it with an urgency that was
never there I've denied the Soviets
their pride my argument I've ended my by
saying by saying that the real end of
the Second World War came in the 1980s
the real reward for all those veterans
who are sacrificed so much um came when
the Soviet tyranny collapsed and the
worst consequences of Soviet behavior in
forty-five was undone thank God without
another conflict max eighteen has to
take get a nine o'clock train to New
York so we're beginning to run it very
short on time I'm gonna ask the people
who are in line to each ask their
question and then ask max Hastings if he
can succinctly put them all together
answer that we can get our book signed
and get it get him out of here in time
to get his train thanks so if you just
eat you ask your question picking up on
Stalin and I've read fair amount and
lived in Ukraine and I've not been able
to sort out of that 20 million 30
million 27 million whatever first does
that include all the people who died in
the gulags second
has anyone ever calculated how many some
sort of difference between how many
people could died as a result in the
book and what I've said is first of all
all very large numbers about the second
world war a guesstimate none of them
should ever regard is conclusive but it
is one of the key qualifiers I said when
you name those 27 million we shall never
know how many of them were killed by the
Germans and harmony by Stalin's own
people because in the gulag they were
going on the best estimates we know they
were still dying in the gulag at the
rate of several hundred thousand you
will never have a conclusive answer but
you're asking a very pertinent question
that 27 million are a good many and so
if Stalin and had such a thing as a
conscience a good many of them should
have been on his yeah I think a majority
thank you for a very enlightening talk I
have a question in your earlier remarks
you had a you made an observation that
you weren't sure that a lot of young
Germans knew that much about their
history I was in high school in Germany
56 59 and they weren't getting it really
in the high schools maybe for some
obvious reasons because one question
would lead to another and where you
there's a lot of interest a lot of shame
etc but one thinks that it certainly
since the 1970s Germany's come to close
scripts with its history where the
mantle of its history very seriously and
you saying what you just said sounds
quite disturbing especially in light of
the reunification you're allowed I think
you alluded to Poona Monday and as you
know nearby was Stalag leuf one at Barth
Germany marshal zhukov forces liberated
that particular camp do you have any
assessment of marshal Zhukov at that
stage of the war Zhukov I've said in the
book was the most effective military
commander of the war but of course he
did it over the bodies of his own men
and if Zhukov had been commanding
American or British citizen soldiers it
might have looked different Zhukov
achieved his extraordinary achievements
at the price of absent ruthlessness
about the lives of his own people David
Eisenhower who wrote quite a good book
on the war in Europe theorizes that one
of the reasons maybe the major reason
for his grandfather's inhibition if it
was that was a fear that the Russians
might make a separate peace even almost
to the end I wondered if you found any
sport for that but it's it's wrong the
other way around I think that the
evidence suggests that it was the
Russians who were morbidly sensitive
about the dangers of the West and for
example so when occasionally during the
course of the war some very brave
Germans did make advances through
neutral embassies to arm out the Allies
the Americans or the British they were
always sent packing because the
Americans the British were terrified of
saying or doing anything to feed
Stalin's paranoia that the West would
make a separate peace circle other way
around actually Eisenhower in read
Churchill by sending is the
tourists signal to Stalin saying had no
designs on Berlin what actually was
perfectly rational but the reason
Eisenhower did that was because he knew
that Stalin was completely convinced
that the West we're trying to first of
all have the glory of Berlin themselves
and secondly a mega separate peace thank
you for your time
very short just as you're right who do
you consider your audience mentally as
you picture them as you write for them
gosh
I suppose one tries to answer the
questions to the interests one want
oneself and hope that other people are
interested as well that it comes back to
what I was saying about people's
personal stories that I just find I can
sit all night in some suburban bungalow
in Germany or in the United States or in
Britain or in Russia listening to old
men and women talking about the things
that happen in the merrier